we finished off the last video in the
Hadean Eon it was named for it was named
for Hades or the ancient Greek
underworld Hades is also the name of the
God that ran the Greek underworld Zeus
is Zeus's oldest brother and it was an
appropriate name although the idea of
that the ancient Greek notion of the
underworld isn't exactly the the more
modern notion of Hell but it was a
hellish environment you had all this
lava flowing around you had things
impacting the earth from space and as
far as we can tell right now it was
completely inhospitable to life and to
make matters worse even though the earth
started to cool down a little bit maybe
the solid the crust became a little bit
more solid maybe the collisions started
to happen less and less as we started to
go a few hundred million years fast
forward after Thea rammed into the the
early Earth and formed the moon there
was something called the late heavy
bombardment and right now the consensus
is that life whatever we are descended
from would have had to come about after
the late heavy bombardment because this
was a time where so many things from
outer space were hitting earth it was so
violent that it might have killed off
any kind of primitive self-replicating
organisms or molecules that might have
existed before it and I won't go into
the physics of the late heavy
bombardment but we believe that it
happened because Uranus and Neptune so
this is the Sun right here that is the
Sun this is the asteroid belt this is
the asteroid belt that's outside that's
outside the orbits of the inner rocky
planets that Uranus and Neptune their
orbits their orbits moved outward their
orbits moved outward and I'm not gonna
go into the physics but what that caused
is it caused some it gravitationally it
caused a lot of the asteroids in the
asteroid belt to move inward and start
impacting the inner planets and of
course earth was one of the inner
planets and I should make the Sun I
should make the Sun like orange or
something not blue I don't want you
think that's earth and also impacted the
moon and it's more obvious on the moon
because the moon did not have an
atmosphere to kind of smooth over the
impact so the consensus is that only
after the late heavy bombardment was
earth kind of
ready for life and we believe that the
first life formed 3.8 to four billion
years ago remember G for Giga four
billion years ago when we talk about
life at this period we're not talking
about squirrels or panda bears we're
talking we're talking about extremely
simple life forms we're talking about
prokaryotes and let me give you a little
primer on that right now that we go into
much more detail in the biology playlist
pro4 oh we're talking about prokaryotes
and I'll I'll compare them to eukaryotes
you carry oats you carry oats
prokaryotes are for the most part
unicellular unicellular organisms that
have no nucleuses they also don't have
any other membrane-bound what we'd
called organelles or these little parts
of the cells that perform specific
functions like mitochondria so their DNA
is just kind of floating around let me
draw this character's DNA so it's just
floating around just like that and
prokaryote before kernel or before a
nucleus eukaryotes eukaryotes do have a
nucleus where all of their DNA so this
is this is the nuclear membrane and then
all of its DNA is floating is floating
inside of the nucleus and then it also
has other membrane-bound organelles
mitochondria is kind of the most famous
of them so it also has things like
mitochondria we'll learn more about that
in future videos mitochondria we believe
it's essentially one prokaryote crawling
inside of another but prokaryote and
becoming and kind of starting to become
a symbiotic organism with each other but
I won't go into that right now but when
we talk about life at this period we're
talking about prokaryotes and we still
have prokaryotes on the on the planet
bacteria and archaea are examples of
prokaryotes and just to give you a
little bit of a tidbit right here this
is kind of a this kind of shows our
current understanding of where we think
things branched off from so at this
point of the tree is some common
ancestor to prokaryotes and eukaryotes
so these are the prokaryotes right over
here the bacteria in the archaea
and here is the eukaryotes and this
first living thing or this first set of
living things we think might have just
been some type of self-replicating
molecules and slowly some membrane might
have come around and it became a little
bit more organized DNA RNA maybe that
maybe RNA was that original
self-replicating molecule became the
Metin the method of kind of transmitting
information from one generation to the
next so it's really still an open
question of exactly what what that first
life is or even how do you define that
first life but based on based on
studying the genetic makeup of molecules
of the current organisms this is how we
think the Tree of Life came about so we
have one common ancestor then they broke
apart and then the archaea and
eukaryotes have a common ancestor that's
different from the bacteria and we'll
talk more about that in the future and
this right here just so you can
visualize it this is an example of
bacteria this is this is e coli or ISA
ricci coli that's just an example of
bacteria comes in a bunch of shapes and
forms but it's a pro carry otic life
form and the earliest life forms the
earliest life forms we also think we're
anaerobes these are things that did not
need one that they did not need oxygen
and they for the most part found oxygen
poisonous and the earliest life forms
also probably did not perform
photosynthesis they might have gotten
their energy from other sources
chemically from this kind of extremely
volatile environment that they were in
at that time so if we fast forward a
little bit and this is actually a major
event in the history of Earth and these
are huge timescales we're talking about
I mean remember I'm kind of just
nonchalantly saying Oh 4.6 billion years
ago - 3.8 billion you know that's just
800 million years remember and I'll talk
about this you know you know a grass has
only existed for 50 million years this
is 800 million years humans and champion
chimpanzees only diverged 5 million
years ago this is 800 million years
we're talking about you know from from
from ancient Greece to now we're only
talking about about 2500 years 2500
years you multiply that times a thousand
you multiply that times a thousand you
get two and a half million years so we
can
and and this is 800 million years we're
talking about so these are extremely
huge periods of time and that's why we
call them eons you know eons are 500
million to billion years
now the dividing line between the Hadean
Eon and the Archaean Eon and it's kind
of a fuzzy dividing line but most people
place it about 3.8 billion years ago is
kind of before the art is kind of the
earliest rocks that we can observe and
so we can we have rocks from that are
roughly 3.8 billion years ago so we kind
of put that as the beginning of the
Archaean Eon and so there's two things
there one rocks have survived from the
beginning of the Archaean Eon and also
that's roughly when we think that that
the first life existed in there so we're
now in the Archaean Eon and you might
say oh maybe Earth is a more pleasant
place now but it would not be it still
has no too little oxygen in the
environment if you were to go to earth
at that time it might have looked
something like this it would have been a
reddish sky you would have had you would
have had nitrogen and methane and carbon
dioxide and the atmosphere there would
have been nothing for you to breathe
there still would have been a lot of
volcanic activity this right here these
are pictures of stromatolites
stromatolites stromatolites and these
are formed from these are formed from
bacteria that are bringing in sediment
particles and over time these things get
built up but the most significant event
in the Archaean period at least in my in
my humble opinion was what we believe
started to happen about 3.5 billion
years ago and this is prokaryotes or
especially bacteria evolving to actually
utilize energy from the Sun to actually
do photosynthesis and the real the real
fascinating byproduct of that other than
the fact that they can now use energy
directly from the Sun is that it started
to produce oxygen so starts start to
produce produce oxygen and at first this
oxygen even though it was being produced
by the cyanobacteria by this
Bluegreen bacteria it really didn't
accumulate in the atmosphere because you
had all of this iron that was dissolved
in the oceans and let me be clear all of
the life that we're going to be talking
about for really the next several
billion years it all occurred in the
ocean we had no ozone layer now you the
land was being irradiated the land was
just a completely inhospitable
environment for life so all of this was
occurring in the ocean and so the first
oxygen that actually got produced it
actually was it actually got it actually
instead of just being released into the
atmosphere it ended up bonding with the
iron that was dissolved in the ocean at
that time so it actually didn't have a
chance to accumulate in the atmosphere
and we're going to when we fast-forward
past the Archaean period we're going to
see that once a lot of that iron was
oxidized and the oxygen really did start
to get released in the atmosphere it
actually had a you know it's funny to
say a cataclysmic effect or a
catastrophic effect on the other life of
the other anaerobic life on the planet
at a time and it's funny to say that
because it was a catastrophe for them
but it was kind of a necessary thing
that had to happen for us to happen so
you know for us it was a blessing that
this cyanobacteria started to pump out a
lot of oxygen and eventually oxidized
all of the iron and eventually released
a lot of oxygen in the atmosphere and
killed off all of this anaerobic
bacteria so that eventually we could you
know us us us oxygen breathing organisms
could come about but that's not going to
happen for a while we still have a few
billion years before things start things
start flopping around on the land anyway
see in the next video